hey guys welcome back to another video
has simply alone in today's video we'll
be learning all about react installation
on windows so without further ado let's
get started to setup the reactive
element environment we need two things
installed node and the text editor of
your choice so let's begin by installing
node.js we can head to the official
node.js web site say download nodejs so
here you can see the windows installer
depending on your system you can either
download the 32-bit version or the
64-bit version so I'm going to go ahead
and click on the 64-bit version since
it's already installed on my system I'm
not again installing node you can follow
the installation guidelines and download
it once you're done with node
installation you can go ahead and
download a text editor of your choice so
I'd suggest vs code so let's head to the
vs code page say download code click on
the first link and download the 64-bit
version for Windows once you're done
with the installation of both node and
your text editor you can start creating
your first react application so for that
let's create a folder I'm creating it on
my desktop while you can create it in
any of your drives let's call it first
react now open your command prompt now
you can type in the path for the folder
that you just created so say CD users
first yeah now go ahead and type in the
command npm install - g create react
okay so this command installs all the
necessary react.js modules now to check
if the version is correctly installed
you can type in create react half
version so you can see the version here
now let's continue and develop your
react application type in the command
create gif and you can give a name to
your application so I say in my app now
this should take a couple of minutes
okay once you've successfully create
your application they say to begin by
typing the following commands so let's
do that
say CD my and NPM start this should
typically start your application and
here we go alright you can also open
your application in the text editor that
you've downloaded so let's go ahead and
open vs col vs code file open folder go
to your desktop or the tribe that you've
saved your folder in first react my app
and I say select folder so as you can
see all your modules have been imported
you can click on app dorje s and start
editing
alright so that is it for this video if
you have any queries regarding
installation make sure you leave a
comment below and I'll be happy to help
you until then keep learning and happy
coding
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simple learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos de nerd up and get certified
click here